every second about 16 million tons of
water evaporates from the surface of the
earth during that same second
16 million tons of water falls back down
to the earth
as rain but water isn't the only type of
precipitation we experience
due to certain weather conditions all
kinds of crazy stuff has fallen from the
sky
things like frogs snakes spiders animal
flesh
even blood have rained down all over the
world for centuries
oh this is sounding ominous well it's
more common than you think
in fact in honduras they celebrate yuvia
de peses
which means reign of fish now honduras
is a landlocked nation with the nearest
body of water 120 miles away
yet every spring it rains thousands of
fish all over the town of euro
and these fish are completely aquatic
we're not talking about flying fish
what do you mean flying fish there are a
few species of fish that can fly well
technically they glide but it's pretty
amazing actually amazing
i'll say it's like it's like
a whole new world
all new stuff for me to see
i'll just fly along and sing this song
it's a whole new world for me
what anyway fish rain snake rain
blood rain it's weird and it's real
let's find out why
[Music]
welcome to the y-files where smart folks
like us come to laugh and learn
today we're talking about the phenomenon
of reigning
animals animal rain has been documented
throughout human history pliny the elder
talked about a storm of frogs and fish
as early as the first century a.d in the
late 18th century
french soldiers saw frogs falling from
the sky during a heavy rain near the
city of lille this story
fascinated french physicist andrei
mariam peer
yes that ampere who was one of the first
scientists to take these stories
seriously and pierce speculated that
violent winds
could pick up large numbers of small
animals and carry them great distances
he might be right the current working
hypothesis
is that animal rain involves tornadic
waterspouts
which are tornadoes that form over water
water spouts usually occur in the
tropics
but they can occur anywhere europe
australia antarctica
even over america's great lakes if the
conditions are right waterspouts
typically form as their parent clouds
are developing over warm water
did i say womb you did
as the warm water evaporates humid air
is pulled up toward the cloud
as more humid air pours in a vortex can
form
in these vortexes vortices can grow to
be 300 feet wide 90 meters
and 2 000 feet tall 600 meters large
water spouts can be violent and
dangerous
when they reach speeds of 160 kph
they can damage ships airplanes and put
people's lives in jeopardy
anything within a meter of the water's
surface can be lifted into the air
if the water spout is powerful enough
these animals can be carried all the way
up to the parent cloud and sometimes
even stay up there for miles
after the water spout is long gone fish
specifically are small light and flat
and they're light enough that they can
be buffeted up and down within a cloud
for a long time
don't you dare oh fine this is what
scientists believe is happening in
honduras
a water spout is pulling fish from the
ocean and carrying them far
inland others speculate there's an
underground river that's carrying the
fish closer to the town
still something is lifting them in the
air is it a water spout
it could be they're common in that part
of the world but reports of fish rain
have occurred
all over the planet as recently as 2017
in india and sri lanka
but also mexico wales saskatchewan
california even philadelphia
pennsylvania recently
on september 9th 2016 lisa lowbry was
out for a walk in the suburbs of philly
now she hears a rustling in the trees
above her she looks up
and she gets smacked in the face with a
five pound catfish
[Laughter]
that's not funny she ended up with a cut
on her eye oh
is she all right well she's all right
now but
now the shoes that he had a fin
people catching fish boring but
fish catching people oh boy
it hurts it hurts me now nobody's sure
how a catfish can fall from the sky in
philadelphia
some people have speculated that a bird
was carrying it but that had to be a
pretty large bird
it could grip it by the husk just a few
months ago
thousands of small fish reigned on the
town of yahweh australia
what makes this so weird is that yawa is
500 miles inland
and some of the fish were alive and the
waterspout theory doesn't address
why some incidents of animal rain only
consist of one species
and not all kinds of different animals
of the same size let's look at a few of
[Music]
these
just kidding that was that was just a
bad movie yeah i rather enjoyed it
spiders now this one's not a horror
movie but it definitely looks like one
let's go back to the terror continent
called australia
on may 15 2015 residents of goldburn
australia
witnessed millions of baby spiders
literally
raining down and blanketing the
countryside in
silky white whips what happened in this
case is called ballooning which is a
form of spider transportation
spiders will climb to the top of the
highest tree or structure they can
then spin a web into a sort of parachute
that catches a breeze which can carry
them a long way
they do this to escape predators seek
food or to establish new territories
when a spider is getting ready to travel
it will raise its legs and sample the
airflow once it's satisfied it orients
its abdomen skyward
spins a little silk and off it goes
normally this goes unnoticed because
spiders
typically travel one at a time but
sometimes like in goldburn
the weather conditions were so favorable
to ballooning that thousands of spiders
took the air simultaneously
the same thing happened in brazil
however these weren't baby spiders
these were nightmare spiders deuce
folks in brazil were pretty upset i mean
before this video i didn't know how to
say the world is ending in portuguese
but
i do now if you want to see more of that
i'll link to some spider rain videos
below
worms worms from the sky is strange
because it can occur in calm weather as
well as stormy
and worms don't seem to mind the cold
either thousands of worms appeared on a
snowy mountain in norway in 2015
and scientists still don't know how it
happened the worms were first noticed by
a skier
who said the mountain was covered with
thousands of them he assumed they were
dead but then he grabbed a few
and they were alive how the worms
couldn't have come from the ground
because under the snow
was about a meter of soil frozen solid
so general consensus is that a violent
air pocket
lifted the worms and then dropped them
on the mountain but from where
where are there thousands of live worms
in the mountains in norway in march
nobody knows sweden same thing raining
worms
how so i did some research and it seems
that this has been happening in
scandinavia since at least the 1920s
and in europe far before that nobody
knows why
they're under the ground they're under
the ground
scotland 2011 so many sky worms
reigned on a middle school football game
that they had to call up the game and go
inside
there's wee worms everywhere let's go
texas 2015 clumps of earthworms appeared
in the middle of the street out of
nowhere
hundreds of them in piles in the street
from where aurora michigan 2016
skyworms tucson arizona 2018
sky worms
this is sounding a lot less like weather
and more like an invasion
blood oh nothing is better at whipping
up a little local hysteria
like raining blood
cases of blood rain or red rain have
been recorded since
homer's iliad and throughout history in
europe alone there are hundreds of
reports of blood rain going back
centuries
and every time it occurred it was
considered supernatural and a bad almond
in the year 787 a.d there was a recorded
rain of blood that was later said to
predict the viking invasion of england
in germany a shower of blood in 1347 was
followed by the arrival of the black
plague
so you know they just connected the dots
bloodrayne
bad plague bad
one of the first scientists to try to
prove this phenomenon was not
supernatural
was giuseppe maria giuvene bloodrain
fell into italy in 1803
and juventus correctly came to the
conclusion that sand from africa was
pulled high in the atmosphere across the
adriatic and mixed with storm clouds to
turn the water
red in 2001 blood rain received
international attention
when it fell on kerala india initial
studies showed the rain had large
amounts of nickel titanium iron and
other metals this led to a theory that
the red rain was caused by an
atmospheric meteor burst now that sounds
super cool
but further study showed that the rain
contained spores
of a specific type of algae indigenous
to austria that had migrated to india in
the upper atmosphere after another
incident of red rain and kerala in 2012
studies have confirmed with certainty
that the microalgae trentofolia is
indeed turning the rain red
so no blood rain is not actually blood
except when it is march 3rd 1876
was the famous kentucky meat storm that
doesn't sound like a derby
for several minutes small chunks of meat
fell from the sky
on a farm in rankin kentucky enough meat
to fill a large wagon so the story goes
reports say it appeared to be beef
but according to an issue of scientific
american two gentlemen who tasted the
meat thought it was either lamb
or deer unknown mates fell from the sky
and someone ate it
yep and joe rogan wasn't there nope
gross yup studies of the meat determined
it was lung tissue either from a horse
or from a human infant oh nobody noticed
a missing baby
or a missing horse who was in charge of
this investigation
transylvania university so dracula ate
the baby
no no transylvania university's in
lexington kentucky
i'm so confused oh you're not the only
one a scientific reason for the kentucky
meat storm was never settled
but locals think it came from vultures
who when threatened will regurgitate
everything in their stomachs to make a
quicker getaway
and when one vulture vomits they all do
oh there's so much blood
don't you start doing that no you're
gonna make the buzzard
vomit okay fine but nine days later
on march 12 1876 the same thing
happened in london england
still no explanation well it does
explain english cooking
snakes the famous snake rain occurred in
memphis
in 1877. reports say thousands of black
snakes
reigned from the heavens and slithered
all over the streets
snakes of all sizes some they say were
over a foot long
oh i really wanted this one i really did
every list
article and video about weird rain has
this story in it
thousands of snakes thudding to the
ground writhing around and hissing
that's youtube gold we had clips from
indiana jones
and sam l jackson photos and b-roll that
would have
it would have blew your mind but those
of you who followed the y-files since
the beginning
know that even though we're a goofy
channel we do try to get the facts right
this was a huge national story in 1877.
it was picked up by the new york times
and it was reprinted in newspapers all
around the country
but nobody fact-checked they just
regurgitated the same story
19th century clickbait nothing ever
changes
there was actually only one eyewitness
to the memphis snake rain
and she didn't really see them fall they
were already on the ground she said the
snakes were black
and clumped together but when rinsed
with water they turned flesh in color
they also didn't move like snakes she
said they gathered up their bodies
in horseshoe shapes and creeped along
the ground
that's how worms move oh i love how to
do that
the infamous snake reign of memphis of
was probably earthworms but i did find
actual newspaper stories from pierre
south dakota 1870 columbus kentucky 1907
and san francisco 1909 all talking about
actual live snakes falling from the sky
i have had it with these
snakes on this plane
i'm glad we worked that in links below
tadpoles in 2009 the entire country of
japan was
covered in dead tadpoles i mean the
entire country
they were first spotted in ishikawa
which is on the west coast of japan
but dead tadpoles were reported in towns
and villages
and on cars all over the country in one
incident
a 55 year old man who was caught in a
tadpole downpour
described hearing a strange sound in the
parking lot of a civic center in the
city of danao
and upon further exploration he found
100 tadpoles covering the windshields of
cars
the now is in the middle of the island
miles away from ishikawa and there are
two
theories for what happened here both of
which we discussed and i believe
neither of them first explanation water
spout but even local meteorologists
aren't buying this because
the weather was clear the winds were
light and it doesn't explain how
tadpoles got
scattered everywhere the second
explanation is that large birds like
herons or crows or seagulls
drop the tadpoles while being disturbed
mid-flight
fine but again how does this happen
across an entire country simultaneously
nobody knows or they won't tell us
frauds it's been raining frogs for a
long time
even the bible's book of exodus talks
about a swarm of frogs as one of the
plagues
it might not have been a metaphor this
is a real thing that happens
periodically in different places around
the world
not just in paul thomas anderson movies
in 1873 kansas city missouri experienced
a rainstorm that covered the entire city
in frogs
same thing happened in minneapolis in
1901 where the frogs were so
thick that travel was impossible
leicester mass 1953
sheffield uk 1995. but we don't need to
comb through old newspapers to find
stories about reigning frogs we just
have to go back
to 2010. in june of 2010 in hungary
thousands of tiny frogs reigned all over
the country
and many of them were still alive can a
waterspout do this if you drop a frog
from a building
it goes splat and in all the cases i
mentioned hungary included there were no
reports of weird weather or wind or
waterspouts and in this particular case
in hungary frogs were falling for
several days across the whole country
some zoologists claim that this is
common migratory behavior for frogs
that's fine but then how do the frogs
get on top of cars and buses and
buildings
answer me that zoologists now this is an
ongoing debate but i find it really
interesting that there are all these
reports of animal rain
but very little video of the animals
actually falling
and lack of evidence brings out all
kinds of theories from the wrath of god
to
alien intervention and that brings us
to star jelly jelly
before hollywood icon steve mcqueen was
dubbed the king of cool
he starred in a little horror movie
called the blob
the blob was released in 1958 and it's a
well-known film to horror fans and
hollywood history buffs
what's up what's not so well known is
the inspiration for the blob
the plot goes like this it's a small
town in rural pennsylvania two teenagers
are making out on lover's lane when they
see a meteorite crash
just over yonder later an old feller
investigates the site and naturally he
pokes the meteorite with a stick it
breaks open and a small jelly-like
substance oozes out
attacks him and he goes screaming off
for help
[Music]
28 year old teenager steve mcqueen picks
him up and takes him to a doctor the
rest is movie history
but the blob was inspired by a real
event
in 1950 four philadelphia policemen
reported the discovery of a domed disk
of quivering jelly six feet in diameter
and one foot thick at the center and an
inch or two near the edge when they
tried to pick it up
it dissolved into an odorless sticky
scum the producer of the blob jack
harris
is from pennsylvania and he was
fascinated with the local star jelly
legend an
outbreak of star jelly happened as
recently as 2013
at the ham wall nature reserve in
england but star jelly occurs all over
the world so it has a lot of names
star slime star slubber in german it's
called
sternerhotz which means stars not in
spanish it's
caca de luna which i was going to say
excrement
oh you're such a slave to the youtube
algorithm grow up here
sky jelly is a gelatinous substance
that's been found in grass but also in
branches of trees
and reports of sky jelly go back
centuries and explanations range from
frog eggs to bacteria to alien organic
matter
to the paranormal so what is it we don't
know star jelly usually dissolves or
evaporates
as soon as it's discovered so we don't
have a lot of samples but scientists in
the national geographic society tested a
sample in the u.s
they found no dna at all so what is it
we don't know oh i don't care for that i
don't either
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files have you ever
witnessed weird things or animals
falling from the sky or heard stories
about it post them in the comments so we
can all check them out we're just
getting started here at the y file so do
us a favor hit that subscribe
button become a founding filer you can
help us shape the content of the channel
and if there's a subject you'd like us
to cover
put in the comments we put a ton of work
into these videos so if you enjoy
watching them
do us a favor hit the thumbs up nothing
helps out a new channel like a thumbs up
baby i hope we earned your subscription
today but if we didn't
i promise we'll keep making fun brainy
content until we do earn it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you
are appreciated
you